bonjour maître de conférence en
géopolitique à Sciences Po spécialiste
des relations Europe Russie alors on n'a
pas on n'a pas pu aller jusqu'au bout
mais on a compris le message en Ukraine
il y a des mots qui résonnent en Russie
pour autant sur le terrain pour le
moment en tout cas rien ne change les
Ukrainiens ont l'avantage ont repris
l'avantage dans certaines régions chaque
camp évidemment tient ça tient sa
posture j'aimerais avoir votre réaction
à vous après ce discours de Vladimir
Poutine et c'était annonce de la
mobilisation de la réserve russe merci
donc vraiment je pense la première chose
à quoi on doit faire attention c'est
la logique de la mobilisation partielle
et de ce chiffre donc 300000 ohms pour
l'instant déjà
tout ce qui était dit sur la
mobilisation en général depuis le début
de la guerre a été fait à l'inverse par
la Russie d'abord en mars on avait des
proclamations du président que que les
professionnels donc sous contrat vont à
se battre à Ukraine et pas des
des soldats qui qui sont là pour leur
service militaire normal donc d'aller
plus jeune et ne pas aller plus jeune ni
des réservistes ensuite sachant donc en
juin et maintenant on a pas seulement
les réservistes pas seulement à tout ce
que possible mais aussi on a des
mobilisation partielle il faut se
rappeler que tout le monde qui a voulu
que la motivation principale des soldats
russes pour aller faire la guerre en
Ukraine c'est pas les patatisme parce
que déjà le territoire de la Russie n'a
jamais été envahi c'est tout se passe
toutes les guerres c'est pas sur le
territoire crainiennes mais c'est
l'argent donc les gens sont promis
l'équivalent de
douzaine de fois d'une salaire annuel de
12 élèves mensuel normal donc par mois
et il y a beaucoup de gens qui se
parlent surtout dans les régions où les
gens ne voient pas beaucoup de d'argent
leur salaire et il n'est pas beaucoup
d'emplois et surtout aujourd'hui à tout
ce qui est déjà les situations
économiques dégradantes deuxièmement
donc c'est à dire que tout le monde qui
a voulu faire la guerre et c'est déjà
sorti donc il reste les gens qui se sont
déjà étaient rappelés ils sont déjà en
Ukraine et donc il reste des gens qui ne
veulent pas être mercenaires mais qui
vont que même être appelé et donc la
question c'est quoi concrètement en
Russie c'est quoi le profil c'est c'est
la personne qui a passé service
militaire par exemple quand elle avait
18 ans ou c'est obligatoire le service
militaire mais qui ensuite non plus rien
à faire avec le militaire ils n'ont
jamais travaillé dans le militaires
professionnels ils sont allés travailler
dans le travail normal et ensuite par
contre il reste toujours dans mes
réserves comme une personne qui sait
utiliser des armes donc ça peut être
mais qui vont quand même devoir
appeler à tout moment mais qui vont
quand même devoir subir un entraînement
c'est ce que disait le président russe
et c'est ça les former de nouveau et
c'est ça la question exactement déjà les
formats de nouveau donc ça peut prendre
du temps est-ce que ça va vraiment être
fait est-ce que la formation ça peut
prendre deux semaines tant que ça peut
prendre trois mois et deuxièmement en
vue le nombre
militaire pas seulement de très haut
niveau mais aussi de tout le niveau
moyen et N+1 tu es donc c'est on parle
des milliers et des milliers de
personnes de niveau de dirigeants très
très direct et communiqué par Kremlin
aujourd'hui moins de 6000 hommes il est
fortement contesté très fortement
contesté peut-être à moins de 6000 ans
c'est juste justement c'est dirigeants
de très bon niveau qui sont nécessaires
qui sont donc responsables pour tout ce
qui se passe sur le terrain ils sont
très opérationnels qui ont été beaucoup
pas beaucoup détruit par dans dans cette
guerre déjà donc ils sont te tuer et
donc là il s'agit pas seulement ce que
je veux dire de former des gens
d'utiliser le kalachnikov il s'agit et
pas seulement même de les former
d'utiliser les technologies plus
complexes mais aussi de les former à
mener d'autres personnes dans le combat
et peut-être il s'agit des personnes qui
eux-mêmes ont utilisé quoi que ce soit
on ne t'aime jamais dans le combat et
ont eu l'entraînement militaire il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'années mais surtout
qui n'ont jamais eu cette expérience de
manière les autres dans le combat il y a
toute cette couche aujourd'hui qui est
très très endommagée il y a des images
qui commence à circuler sur les réseaux
sociaux de la garde nationale qui est va
chercher ses réservistes à domicile il y
a cette question qui se pose qu'elle
accueille va recevoir cette annonce de
Vladimir Poutine en Russie la chasse
comme on m'a dit un analyste russe très
très très célèbre la chasse à la
population est ouverte je pense pas que
il y a déjà d'ailleurs dans tout ce
qu'on a vu la communication du
gouvernement c'est pas seulement à se
montrer chez vous que les gens puissent
vous prendre parce que bien sûr de chez
vous vous pouvez vous cacher chez votre
rente chez votre et grammaire ou chez
votre ami mais vous pouvez aussi être
pris tout simplement peut-être dans la
rue vous pouvez être donné le petit
papier là où vous travaillez etc etc je
pense que là c'est une vraie chasse à la
population qu'on va observer maintenant
ici la population qui bien évidemment a
peur qui n'a pas du tout motivé d'y
aller pour pour se sacrifier pour rien
du tout la base de logique est très
faible et donc là c'est sur un vrai
question comment cette population va
réagir il y a beaucoup de réactions
quasiment dans la foulée de cette
intervention de Vladimir l'Occident a
réagi beaucoup de réactions la dernière
l'Union européenne qui voit dans cette
mobilisation des réservistes le désarroi
de Vladimir Poutine est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça est-ce qu'il ne faut
pas s'en inquiéter justement
je pense que effectivement on voit d'un
côté c'est un signe de reconnaissance de
la faiblesse et de la perte d'autres
côtés tout ce qui est justement le mot
partiels c'est ça qui me perturbe parce
que ce chiffre à 300000 personnes il
faut se rappeler c'est presque deux fois
plus de ceux avec quoi la Russie a
commencé la guerre c'est plus ou moins
160000 personnes qui étaient
positionnées tout au long de la
frontière ukrainienne en or et à l'est
au début donc de la guerre en février
donc aujourd'hui on parle de nombre de
deux mois de deux fois de plus et oui
bien sûr la qualité ne sera pas le même
mais à le chiffre et la quantité sera
beaucoup plus importante je pense que il
faut pas sous-estimer que même le menace
que ça représente et la mobilisation
elle peut aller jusqu'à des millions de
personnes et donc c'est à dire que on
parle dans la durée si cette cette ombre
va être aussi dommageée ou tu es assez
rapidement on parle de la durée de la
capacité de mobiliser beaucoup beaucoup
plus du monde dans le pays où la vie
d'une personne ne vaut absolument rien
et où le
mécanismes qui peuvent donc
contrôler
l'opinion publique à l'opinion des
élites politiques n'existe pas donc
c'est ça pour moi qui représente le
danger le plus forte on a entendu dans
les mots de Vladimir Poutine l'Occident
nommé directement il assume clairement
cette position l'Occident qui est
désormais visée de façon assumée Poutine
se dit prêt à utiliser tous les moyens
de défense face au face aux Occidentaux
et il agit de nouveau la menace
nucléaire est-ce que ça vous inquiète ça
m'inquiète surtout que la Russie
contrôle la centrale de the corrigia
surtout qu'ils ont déjà bombardé l'autre
centrale à l'Ukraine
et c'est très inquiétant aussi parce que
justement c'est fait partie de la
rhétorique officielle du Kremlin dès le
début de la guerre le Kremlin n'a jamais
été un gars avec le crâne et c'était
toujours un gars avec l'Occident la
propagande russe a toujours vu qu'il est
ce message et maintenant c'est ça
devient ce qui est un peu plus on a pu
une nouvelle étape là si je vous suis
bien
on a juste l'expansion de l'ancienne
étape parce que pour le propagande russe
ils ont toujours été en guerre contre le
temps et pas contre qui Yves c'est même
pas en interlocuteur légal pardon pour
pour le Kremlin c'est c'est vraiment
juste un peu dire un entrait devant le
principal et dans les ultimatumes je
veux rappeler donc du 17 décembre que la
Russie a posé à présenter à l'Occident
et qui ensuite engendrer deux mois de
négociation intense il s'agissait de
revu de l'architecture de la sécurité de
l'Europe et pas des contestation
territoriales de l'Ukraine merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous pour
commenter décrypter donc ces dernières
annonces de